und wir beginnen aber herr altmaier sie
waren 2015 der flüchtlings koordinator
von angela merkel mit den diesen bildern
ihrer belarus polen die grenze was geht
ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie diese
bilder sehen ja ich habe mich ich habe
mich sehr erschrocken weil es mich an
ein anderes drama erinnert zunächst
einmal nämlich dem ausbruch der ukraine
krise 2014 damals ist ein unabhängiges
land die ukraine der stabilisiert wurden
von außen und wir erleben jetzt dass ein
land wie polen die stabilisiert werden
soll deshalb müssen und werden wir den
hohlen helfen wir sind das europäische
union dazu auch bereit das zweite ist
wenn ich diese menschen sind studien
darf ich ganz kurz wenn sie sagen wir
müssen in polen helfen und sie sind als
europäische union wir sind dazu bereit
was meinen sie damit es geht ja darum
dass die grenze so gesichert wird dass
wir dass wir eine destabilisierung
verhindern können dass wir gleichwohl
natürlich auch unseren humanitären
verpflichtungen gerecht werden aber wir
dürfen nicht zulassen dass der letzte
einer der letzten diktatoren europasaal
lukaschenko auf diese art und weise
geschäfte macht und nachbarstaaten die
stabilisiert sich in ihre inneren
angelegenheiten einmischt zu seiner
andere flüchtlingskrise als 2050 er
wollte einmal ein hatten sie sagten
gerade wir wollen einerseits diese
grenze sichern wird braucht nur die
antwort von frau carina zu interessieren
und gleichzeitig unseren humanitären
verpflichtungen nachkommen ein ungutes
gefühl es wird nur eins von beiden gehen
das glaube ich nicht wir haben in der
flüchtlingskrise
2015 gezeigt dass wir diesen zustrom
über den balkan schrittweise
zurückführen konnten und dass wir die
situation der flüchtlinge in der türkei
verbessert haben im übrigen haben wir
auch weiterhin menschen aufgenommen
obschon sie das auch in zukunft menschen
aufnehmen aber wir können und wir dürfen
nicht zulassen noch einmal dass ein
diktator wie herr lukaschenko darüber
entscheidet wie viele menschen nach
deutschland kommen aus anderen ländern
in einer organisierten art von menschen
schlepperei die mit diesem
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert nichts zu
tun hat kann ihn nachvollziehen frau
kader auch schon auf ihrem stuhl hin und
her vielleicht können wir werden sie
antworten von gerade einmal ein bild zu
spielen dass wir heute auch gesehen
haben an eine ganze verlangt von von
polnischen grenzschützern die da stehen
bis an die zähne bewaffnet vor einem
stacheldraht über ihnen schwebt
sozusagen ein helikopter vielleicht
kommt mir diese bilder mal zu spielen
und dann sieht man mal was das bedeutet
wenn wir wirklich sagen wir meinen dass
jetzt ernst wir schützen diese grenze
und die frage ist wie lange sind wir
bereit die bilder auszuhalten frau
erstmal würde mich interessieren ob
deutschland hohen rückhalt gibt für das
was die polen nämlich machen nämlich
eigentlich eu-rechtswidrig
buschbeck zu machen also die
asylsuchenden die schutzsuchenden er
dass ich mit diesem hubschrauber also
ist völlig absurd wenn auch also die
polen versucht ja die schutzsuchenden
nicht rein zu lassen was eigentlich
gegen eu recht verstößt weil man ja sagt
wer asyl sucht muss das erst einmal
beantragen können in der eu und ich
finde das ist eine sondersituation hier
werden ja menschen sozusagen extra hin
gefahren hin geschickt genug eingeflogen
so dass ich finde in dieser situation
kann polen zurückweisungen machen
bekommt aber tatsächlich von brüssel
nicht und auch aus deutschland von der
bundesregierung insgesamt noch keinen
rückhalt dafür also was heißt das wenn
sie jetzt sagen wir helfen genau wie
soll diese hilfe aussehen hat man ja
darüber darüber wird der mit polen
gesprochen das ist zunächst einmal geht
es von der europäischen union aus wir
sind alle anderen mitgliedsstaaten dann
in der verpflichtung uns auch zu
engagieren
das verhältnis zu polen war ja
kompliziert in den letzten monaten weil
polen auch in einigen punkten
innenpolitisch mit rechtsstaatlichen
erfordernissen sagen wir mal sehr
kreativ umgegangen ist nach auffassung
der brüsseler eu-kommission
aber jetzt in dieser situation das
verhalten von lukaschenko ist aus meiner
sicht völkerrechtswidrig das ist ganz
eindeutig so und deshalb hat polen auch
anspruch darauf dass wir
zusammenarbeiten
sie müssen natürlich zunächst einmal
selbst sagen was in dieser situation
besonders notwendig ist mein eindruck
ist dass es nicht so sehr eine
personelle situation ist wo eine
überforderung besteht aber dass man doch
jedenfalls
koordiniert sich abspricht und vorgeht
nicht in den talkshows das entscheidet
aber gemeinsam mit den polen die unsere
verbündeten in der nato und in der
europäischen union unsere partner sind
wo ist angela merkel eigentlich schreibe
ich nicht in der ganzen causa von dennis
angela merkel wo ist olaf scholz wo sind
die leute die das jetzt tun sagen aber
wenn sie sagen hat man ja wir müssen das
gemeinsam entscheiden wir müssen mit
unseren partnern machen das gut so so
kuschelig sowie das ist mal das was ich
hier stattfindet nicht kuschen nicht
immer steht das ist fakt ist dass ich
mal was von wilhelm wird erst einmal das
war man hat der regierungssprecher sich
dazu sehr deutlich geäußert und zwar
insofern dass wir sowohl im gespräch
sind mit den ländern aus denen diese
flüchtlinge kommen weil es ist ja nicht
nur damit getan dass wir uns mit mit
weißrussland auseinandersetzen sondern
wir wollen dass dieses verbringen von
flüchtlingen in flugzeugen von
vorneherein weiß dass das ziel ein
illegaler grenzübertritt ist und dass
sie von schlepperorganisationen dazu
bewogen haben diese flugzeuge zu
betreten mit dem einzigen ziel illegal
nach europa einzug in den staub und mit
dem einzigen ziel nach deutschland zu
kommen wir können wir das mal zu spielen
deswegen verstehe ich ehrlich gesagt
nicht so richtig warum wir uns da jetzt
wieder versuchen irgendwie aus der
verantwortung zu reden es geht um
deutschland vielleicht können das mal
kurz zu spielen diese diese diese rufe
noch mal deutlich mal hören die leute
rufen deutschland deutschland vielleicht
kommt es im hat muss sein
[Applaus]
so das ist das worum es geht das ist wir
haben da nicht ohne verantwortung das
ist auch menschlich anrührend und
ich habe wirklich glaube ich
ebenso wie die kanzlerin die die
politische verantwortung hat und ich
habe sie unterstützt nach besten kräften
in der größten flüchtlingskrise der
nachkriegszeit wir haben damals alles
getan um diesen menschen zu helfen und
wir haben auch seither unserer
humanitären verantwortung rechnung
getragen aber noch einmal hier geht es
darum dass diese menschen missbraucht
werden sonst kannst du und das darf und
das darf nicht wieder einreißen und
schule machen ansonsten werden wir nicht
mehr herr unserer entscheidung sein und
wird es nachahmer geben in ganz vielen
anderen bereichen die hatten wir doch
schon ich meine wir haben uns frau
gerade abhängig gemacht in gewisser
weise von erdogan der das spiel auch
schon gespielt hat dieses zynische
widerliche spielt mit leuten an die
grenze bringen europa speziell
deutschland zu erpressen jetzt macht es
lukaschenka sie sie in ägypten hat auch
schon versucht der mann mit mit herrn
müller dem entwicklungsminister hier
darüber gesprochen sie nicht doch weil
sie offenbar wissen worum es geht der
mir sagte die sagen ganz offen
leute wie sie sie in ägypten wenn ihr
uns nicht helfen wenn das geld aus
deutschland aus europa nicht fließt dann
schicke ich euch hunderttausend junge
leute seht mal zu wie damit klar kommt
da ist was machen wir denn jetzt ja also
also bei in dem thema türkei damals war
es tatsächlich so dass die türkei über
viele monate allein gelassen wurde von
allen anderen westlichen ländern ja auch
im umgang mit den flüchtlingen aus
syrien aus dem irak da aus dem iran aus
afghanistan und als dort fast zwei
millionen menschen waren und dann diese
menschen begannen oftmals auch unter den
augen der türkischen
grenzpolizisten nach europa zu gelangen
da ist eigentlich die dimension dieses
problems deutlich geworden ich habe mich
nie ab rest gefüllt sondern es war ein
problem für das wir alle verantwortlich
sind wir haben erreicht durch die
zusammenarbeit mit der türkei dass die
dort lebenden flüchtlinge in die schule
gehen können die kinder dass die leute
im krankenhaus behandelt werden können
dass sie eine arbeitserlaubnis haben
dass sie ihren lebensunterhalt verdienen
können die situation ist heute eine ganz
andere als damals und wir haben auch
einen teil der flüchtlinge aufgenommen
insgesamt rund zwei millionen menschen
die in dieser zeit nach europa gekommen
nicht alle nach deutschland aber sehr
viele davon ungefähr zwei drittel nach
deutschland ein drittel nach
skandinavien in niederlande und in die
angrenzenden länder aber frau gerade was
passiert denn wenn wir uns wirklich wir
machen uns noch erpressbar also wenn man
es mal ganz brutal sagt das doch ein
geschäftsmodell das ist eine stete ein
diktat und nach dem anderen sagt okay
das ist der wunde stelle das ist die
weiche stelle dadurch rein genauer
schlagen einfach menschen und wir wir
können solche bilder die können wir
nicht nur aushalten die dürfen wir auch
nicht aushalten wie das foto zb dahinter
kleine kinder die ganz bewusst an diese
grenze geschickt werden da sind menschen
schon erfroren es kommt der winter es
wird kalt ist ein zynisches regelhafte
spiel
ja man muss glaube ich auf lukas
schenkel direkt reagieren oder man kann
an der eskalation an der an der schraube
der sanktionen drehen man müsste aus
meiner sicht auch putin in den blick
nehmen denn lukaschenko macht ja
eigentlich nichts ohne dass putin seine
finger im spiel hat also das könnte die
eu schon an anpacken auch die
fluggesellschaften die beteiligt sind zu
sanktionieren das jetzt passieren als
wäre nett dass auch das auch das hat
glaube ich der regierungssprecher gesagt
dass gesunde auffassung sind dass wir
mit uns die sanktionen anschauen müssen
dass wir überlegen müssen ob sie
verschafft werden dass wir überlegen
müssen ob sie ausgedehnt werden müssen
auch auf andere akteure außerhalb von
weißrussland das werden wir zwischen 26
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
vorantreiben und zu entscheidungen
führen vorantreiben und zu entscheiden
dabei wären draußen weil wir in der
außenpolitik ist es ist nun mal so in
der europäischen union einstimmig
entscheiden und sie können nicht sie
können nicht auf knopfdruck eine
entscheidung zu sagen zustande bringen
wo sie selbst in der deutschen
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz manchmal
ein halbes jahr brauchen bis es soweit
ist dass man kann die europäische union
wird nicht so lange warten die
dringlichkeit der frage ist erkannt und
ich bin fest überzeugt dass wir in den
nächsten tagen und in den nächsten
wochen uns damit sehr vorrangig
auseinandersetzen werden wer lukaschenko
muss wissen dass wir dieses vorgehen
nicht hinnehmen frau gerade hat gerade
schon das spiel gebracht und ich jetzt
noch mal einen kleinen schritt weiter
lavrov der russische außenminister hat
ist heute ganz
schmerzlos einfach gesagt sagt bitte eu
deutschland dann macht doch einen deal
mit lukaschenko sowie mit erdogan auch
einen deal gemacht hat ist es jetzt
nicht an der zeit mal auch was russland
angeht wirklich klare kante zu zeigen
und zu sagen was auch kein tropfen kann
kein liter gas durch durch nord stream 2
zum beispiel das muss aufhören das geht
doch sei nicht also erstens ist fließt
derzeit kein gang hat nochmals weil die
leitung noch nicht zertifiziert ist der
erste punkt der zweite punkt ist wir
haben in allen krisen seit dem kalten
krieg seit den 70er jahren die energie
und die gasversorgung in europa die
stromversorgung die für den handel mit
anderen energieträgern aus diesen krisen
heraus gehalten weil es eine
lebenswichtige infrastruktur ist und das
wissen alle beteiligten und haben sich
danach gerichtet aber noch einmal die
frage was russland in dieser sache tut
ist eine die ganz bedeutend wichtig ist
russland hat in der vergangenheit das
sage ich als jemand der immer für gute
beziehungen zu den menschen in russland
auch eingetreten ist aber die russische
führung hat in der vergangenheit in
syrien in der ukraine
und jetzt auch im zusammenhang mit den
entwicklungen in weißrussland keine gute
rolle gespielt
um es sehr diplomatisch zu formulieren
ich könnte auch sagen vieles gemacht was
mit westlichen mit internationalen
standards nicht vereinbar ist und
deshalb muss auch der russische
präsident wissen dass wir diese dinge
nicht einfach mit ansehen werden vom
geschäftigen wollte gerade das was geht
dir durch den kopf frank wenn du das
siehst diese bilder sie ist dieses
dilemma auch dass wir da gerade
beschreiben das ist erschütternd und das
ist ja auch erschüttert wenn wir darüber
nachdenken wie lange die halbwertzeit
solcher bilder ist denn wir leben ja
doch in katastrophen reichen zeiten und
wir sehen das jetzt und in zwei drei
wochen ist ein anderes thema wieder auf
den tisch und wir dürfen diese dinge
nicht aus den augen verlieren ich frage
mich hat einfach nur durch wen oder was
ein herr lukaschenka noch zu
beeindrucken wäre und ich glaube
tatsächlich dass zu beeindrucken bricht
ein putin also redet man letzten endes
mit herrn putin gibt es mal war das ist
sagen wir wie es ist also eher
lukaschenko essen mafioso